when you watch the economics analysis on
the news it's so difficult to understand
we've kind of like punished people we've
told them like you are not allowed to
have opinions on the economy because you
can't do math and you're stupid this is
why people feel like they can't have
opinions on the economy and you know
this is I think one of the things which
I would like to achieve is making people
feel like empowered like they have the
right to speak about the economy and be
listened to and Ordinary People to have
the right to say it's it's getting worse
for me and my family I think people
often think that I hate bankers and rich
people but um I don't if there's a group
of people that I can't stand it's these
economists driving up wall and you know
economics is not a physical science
there's no way for me to go and do an
experiment and say here let's let's run
the co economy again but with taxation
on the rich and show how living
standards do better we can't do that
physical experiment all we can do is
predict and that is why Banks pay
millions of pounds a year to good
predictors because that's the best way
to tell who is a good Economist because
we can't do physical experiments and it
drives me mad that these economists who
make policy and protect policy that
protects them and their class and the
rich don't even accept when somebody
consistently out predicts them they
won't even listen to them it drives me
mad